(club music)
- [Dren] It’s something that
you feel a connection
with people automatically.
- [Angel] I don't think
there's a better feeling.
You can move the night with the music
and the energy of the
people can also move me.
It just really feels fulfilling.
(club music)
- Hi, I'm Angel.
- I'm Dren.
- We're twin DJs and producers.
- [Dren] What makes a good
DJ is being observant.
If I play one track and I'm just like
everybody really responded to that,
it's knowing in your
head in a split second
I've got 10 other tracks
that sound just like that.
- [Angel] We do switch off.
Usually every 30 minutes.
She can kind of, like, move off of what I did.
When we're not playing,
we're watching the audience.
- She'll be playing and
I'll come over and whisper.
I'll be like, play that next.
- [Angel] I know when my
twin has it, we'll be okay.
- [Dren] We grew up in the Bronx.
- We grew up in the Bronx, New York.
It's a really Jamaican area.
A lot of reggae playing out
in the streets all the time.
- [Dren] In fifth grade
we entered this program
that helps inner-city youth
that are generally under-privileged.
- We got very lucky, but
some kids don't get as lucky.
We got through middle
school and high school
and we got into Dartmouth and
we both decided to go there.
- To go.
- Hey guys.
- Hey, hi.
- So when we graduated, we
came back to the city.
I was playing with equipment on and off.
I went home one day and I told her
like, this is what we have to do.
After you graduate from college
nobody's thinking you'll
then go on to become a DJ.
It was one of those moments
where you had to be resolute
in what you were doing.
- [Dren] There's no kick yet.
(hip-hop music)
And then the bass hits.
- I kinda like it.
- I think DJing is definitely
a predominantly male industry.
We've heard some negativity
from not even other DJs
but people in audiences.
- And I think it's been
surprising just because
it doesn't feel like DJing
should be a gendered thing.
I take a burden upon
myself to perform better
because we are women.
We do get a lot of good
feedback from girls and women.
- Who want to learn to DJ.
- Who want to learn how to DJ.
- [Dren] If someone told
me that I would end up
being a professional DJ with Angel
I would not have believed it.
- When you follow what you like
and you follow your dreams-
- It can take you anywhere.
(ding)